- I remember, it was your,
was it the scavenger hunt birthday party?
- Yes, you actually saved me as a mom,
because we went into lockdown like a week
before my daughter's birthday.
I had like this huge
party that was planned.
Obviously we had to cancel it,
and then I'm like scrambling.
What am I going to do?
Because I go full on into birthday mode,
and so I reached out to you,
you were so kind.
And you sent her a video message.
- I love the idea.
- [Alyson] And giving her a
hint where one of her gifts was.
She just honestly...
- [Kelly] Anytime you need that.
- [Alyson] And this is the video
of her watching your video.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- [Alyson] And she couldn't
even handle the happiness.
(laughter)
All day, I was such a hero.
She was like, "This is better than
the party ever could have been", honestly.
- [Kelly] I am totally down.
Like at some point I
want to be invited for
the scavenger hunt, because I'm a gamer.
- [Alyson] Okay, well,
you know her birthday is
coming up again soon, because
it's almost been a year.
So what are you doing March 24th?
- I'm probably here.
(laughs)
- [Alyson] Might just
drop her at your house.
Is that okay?
- Yeah, hey,
I love my backyard, it's very magical.